[Music]
and welcome to a special Friday night
edition of Hannity and tonight the walls
are now closing in on the Biden White
House the Atlantic is now calling for
Joe to step aside Biden was just slammed
by the New York Times for being a
deadbeat Granddad also USA Today and
here's fake news CNN quote the slow pace
of Biden's re-election campaign feeds
Democrats 2024 anxiety axios meanwhile
exposed Biden's volatile temper
referring to him as quote Old Yeller
whistleblowers continue to allege
serious crimes committed by Joe and
Hunter including bribery tax violations
money laundering we'll learn a lot more
next week and let's not forget cocaine
and now other drugs we find out were
discovered in the west wing of Joe's
white house but of course they haven't
found the culprit and they're not
looking anymore Biden's trip abroad was
an outright disaster and take a look at
your screen well this was in Finland Joe
nibbling if you will and trying to kiss
a terrified looking toddler creepy Joe
is back but let's be clear Joe Biden's
always been creepy weird and not very
smart but to make matters worse his
cognitive decline has now rendered him
totally completely inept you decide
an hour and 20 minutes
Vladimir and I we I should shouldn't be
so familiar uh Mr zielinski and I uh
talked about the kind of guarantees we
could make in the meantime
the ministry of Copeland's daughter of
Ireland our daughter of Ireland you can
tell that's a 40th slip I'm thinking of
home uh the daughter of Iceland and uh
um and I I want to say I think we've had
a very productive Summit
32nd
freestanding have free 30 free
32 freestanding members ceasing his
attacks on it it's inhumane attacks on
Russia I mean by Russia on Ukraine
how embarrassing right and by the way uh
Joe uh president zielinski is not
Vladimir Putin anyway Biden then
proceeded to trip up the stairs here we
go Whoopsie Daisy once again oh there it
is uh capping a week where the president
was often lost confused and dazed while
other leaders were looking on with just
sheer embarrassment Joe Biden is not fit
to be your commander-in-chief right now
much less another term mark my words he
is one major fall away from what will be
a massive Push by democrats to get him
off the ticket everyone on the planet
realizes this except maybe Joe Biden
himself now even the president's own
radical staffers probably see the
handwriting on the wall they're the ones
that are actually running the country
into the ground while Biden Lee
apparently is constantly recuperating in
Delaware in a camp David and can we get
a list of the visitors to go to see him
every weekend how many doctors might be
on that list and speaking of which today
on his way to Camp David he took no
questions and forgot to salute the
Marine that's an important thing to do
Joe you're the commander-in-chief now
Biden is such a terrible excuse for a
president Democrats who are once
ridiculed to mocked by their own party
including Robert Kennedy Jr Marianne
Williamson Cornell West well they're all
gaining what is serious traction and the
primary polls and if I had to make a bet
I would guess that California governor
Gavin Newsom is receiving an endless
stream of texts he wouldn't answer that
question when I interviewed him begging
him to enter this race take a look how
many times has your phone ping a day
people saying you need to get in this
race because they agree with me that
he's not up to the job
I see where you're going with that I'm
asking no I and I'm not answering
I'm not answering I think that's an
answer anyway how embarrassing for Joe
Biden as fellow Democrats they are ready
to send him out to pasture but it's not
just his steep cognitive decline well
put it simply Joe Biden is slimy his
family's access peddling and sketchy
Farm business deals are a massive real
problem now we're going to learn a lot
more next week his refusal to recognize
his own four-year-old granddaughter
frankly is reprehensible and downright
immoral and cruel his history of
plagiarism and never the non-stop lying
and storytelling is a cause for concern
to everybody in this country he just
tells outright provable lies regularly
and of course the media has been
protecting him maybe not so much now and
his behavior around young women and
small children yeah it is creepy it is
weird so if you're a Democrat and you're
watching tonight ask yourself would you
hire Joe Biden in any job in the real
world would you hire him to work at
McDonald's or Home Depot he's been a
lawyer for decades would you let Joe
Biden represent represent you in a court
of law argue your case before a judge
and a jury would you be comfortable with
your life and his hands would you trust
him with any task big or small now if
the answer to those questions is no you
have an obligation to replace him not
only on the ticket but as president with
someone that is actually aware
articulate competent this is a
constitutional republic you do not have
to rubber stamp his re-election bid and
let's face it Biden's poll numbers are
historically bad there is a big chance
that he loses come November 2024 so make
no mistake tonight there is a chance
that Democrats they will be the ones to
move on from Joe Biden before the
election and replace him and that is is
why the walls are now closing in on the
Biden White House now coming up we're
going to break down Biden's scandals in
detail throughout the show hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else